うーーーーーーーー
余ってたワイン
たくさん飲んで
酔って
寝て起きたはじめしゃちょーです
うーーーーー
はい、というわけでですね
まさきとかと飲んでたんですけども、
後輩が今一人下で寝てる
んですけど、
「ファースト信号機　単発ｂ　２丁入り」
やばい、ねむい
ねむいよー
もっと寝たいけど
うーーーーーーーーっわ
こわいこわいこわい
これ見た瞬間ね、
みんなピンと来ると思うんですけども、
ピストルです。
え、こわい
え、ほんと
待って待って怖い怖い
これ運動会でよく
使われる、あの
位置について、
よーい
ブゥン！！！
のやつです
僕の記憶が正しければ
めちゃくちゃ音がでかかった気がする
僕、音でかいのだぁいすき♡
これたくさん使って♡
いろんな人の眠りを妨げてやりたいなぁ
ただ取り扱いにはやっぱ注意しましょうね
安全かつ残虐に使いたいんで
ここ多分こうすると
なんかもうできるぽいっすね
うぅ...うぅ...うぅ....うぅうぅうぅうぅ
パキィン
うぅぅ？
弾が入ってないのかなぁ
やばいなぁ、遊ぶなって書いてあるなぁ
いや、遊びじゃないすよ
今回遊びでこれを使うわけではありませんからね
下で寝てる後輩が
もうすぐ妹をね、学校に連れてかなきゃいけないんですって
だからさぁ
そいつの朝のスタートを切らせてやりてぇじゃん
最高の朝を迎えさせようや
位置について、よぉ〜い
どん！
でバーンと鳴らして
朝の１日のスタートを切ってもらいたいんで
よぉ〜い、どん！という意味では
間違ってないですので
まぁ、適切な距離を測って
僕がまぁいわゆるあの、審判なんで
布団というスターティングラインから
妹を送るというゴールまで
僕が、スタート切ってやりたいと思います
やばい
これ弾ないと打てないよね？だって
探しますわ
ありましたよw
これで間違いない
これでも多分ね
耳をね、絶対になんか装着した方がいいんですよね
耳栓みたいな
え、こわいこわいこわい
これかぁ
うわ、なにこれ
なんか、こういう感じになってます
これを一個ずつ取って
貼って
やるみたいな
うぅなんか怖くなってきちゃった
ひとまず、耳...耳をちゃんとしなきゃ
ちょっと一発打ってみます
これをここにセットするんだろうねぇ
これでもう引き金引いたら音がなります
いきます
えぇ...はぁ...はぁ...はぁ..はぁはぁ
３・２・１
パァァン
はっ...
ピィィィィイィィン
えぐい
パァン
あっあっあっあっあっあっ
あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
やべ、ダメだ
耳塞いでたからわかんなかったけど
やばい
危ないのでみんな真似しないでね
やぁ、これなら起きるでしょ
起きるっていうかスタートダッシュできるでしょ
とうわけで今から
後輩を起こしに行ってきます
では
位置について
よ〜い
パァァン
はいっ！！！
あぁ始まった！！！！
早く！早く！
始まった始まった！！！！
早く！！！
いってらっしゃ〜い
ふっふっふっ
反応早いなぁwww